-Our first guest tonight i
an Academy Award-, Emmy-, an
Tony-nominated actress
who you know
from "Up in the Air"
and the "Pitch Perfect" movies
She stars in "Stowaway," which
is streaming on Netflix now.
Let's take a look.
-Okay, exactly how much time
do we have before it's too late?
-Technically? 20 days.
-Okay, then
we should take that time.
-No, we need as much of
that margin of error as possible
in case anything else happens.
-Margin of error?
What hypothetical situatio
could be worse than
the one we're in right now
-Worst-case scenario is,
he still dies,
but we die along with him.
-How?
-What's left of the algae is
hanging on by a thread as it is.
-So you're fine just giving up
on a person --
-Realistically, every day
he's still here,
it's a dangerous to all of us.
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Anna Kendrick.
How are you?
-Hi, Seth Meyers!
-It's just lovely to see you
I can tell you that much.
I certainly wish
you were here in person
so we could just small-tal
in the back
before you came out here.
-Oh, no, I'm happy
to not do that.
That's fine.
We've done that enough.
It's usually the same
kind of small talk, right?
I come in, and
you say, "What's up?"
and then you go over
to Martha Stewart
and you say the same kind
of thing to her.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I can kind of game it out
in my head, like,
what we would talk about.
I can sort of feel like, "Okay."
-Okay. Gotcha.
So there's not gonna be an
mourning period for that at all?
-No, no, I'm very happy
to be in my house.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, it's nice
to see your whole face.
But, obviously, we're
living through an era
where a lot of people in publi
are only showing
half their face.
Has this provided you
with any degree of anonymity
-I think the mask thing --
I thought it would.
I mean, I, like, disprovin
all superhero movies,
like, the idea
that from here up, I'm invisible
is pretty silly.
But I have that problem already,
where I did jury duty
a few years ago.
And for three weeks,
I'm on this jury
and I'm, like, chatting
with this woman about --
like, I'm asking her about her
water bottle and whatever.
And then, when the trial ends,
she turns to me and she goes
"I can stop pretending
I don't know who you are now."
And I'm just gagged.
Just -- How could she --
Like, as though,
how could anybody know who I a
if I'm not walking around
with a sign on that says,
"Ask me what movies I'm from."
Or, like, holding a cup
and singing a song.
Like, "How does she know?
Has she discovered my identity?"
Once I'm wearing the mask,
I'm fully invisible.
Like, I could commit murders
Do you need somebody killed?
I'm your man.
I'm like the wind.
How could anybody find me?
-[ Laughs ]
I guess I'm trying to think of
-- I feel like --
do you feel like you have
more recognizable happier face
if people were given
to see half?
-That's a good question.
I don't know. Do you?
-I don't know.
I think I would be --
I think
that's more recognizable.
I think you'd get me more there.
-I think so, too.
I think if I was -- Yeah, like
in the world of superheroes,
I think this is
worse for me than this.
-Yeah, when the sort of
eye-based pandemic starts
and we have to start doing this.
-Yeah, you and I are just --
-Yeah, we're going to be fine.
So, this is a very cool movi
about three astronauts
who are on a two-year missio
to Mars with limited supplies.
I'm sort of loath to give away
some of the many twists
in this film.
But what drew you to the ide
of doing a movie like this
-I mean, Toni Collette,
first of all.
-Yeah.
-Like, the greatest.
That clip is actually --
like, the first take
of that scene,
me and Daniel Dae Kim
turned to each other
and we were like, "Were yo
acting? I wasn't acting."
I was just like, "Oh, my God
Toni Collette
is acting right in my face."
But it is, like, one of these --
you know, it's, like, in space
so that makes it complicated
But it's
a really simple premise.
It is just, like, "Look, there's
four people in a lifeboat,
and there's enough resources
for three."
And how do you decide?
And it's not that we meant to,
but in between takes,
you can't help
but start asking
those questions.
If the four of us,
the cast members, were, like -
how would you make
that kind of decision?
You know?
And then I can't help but going,
"Well, I think box-office
performance is probably a factor
we should consider.
-Sure, sure. I mean, I --
-Toni is going with, like,
critical acclaim and awards.
And Daniel Dae Kim is like
"Well, have any of you
ever carried done a TV show?
-[ Laughs ]
-So that happened.
Shamier is the newcomer.
He wants a chance.
We've all had careers.
We've been doing this
for a while.
He's happy to put us out to sea.
-Right, of course.
This is an interesting
philosophical question
about actors --
which actor provides
the most value to society.
[ Laughs ]
-None of us. None of us.
-We're gonna let you all go.
-Yeah. That would be fair.
Honestly, the pandemic
has proven one thing,
and that is that, like, we
stay in our houses for a year,
nobody notices.
-Everybody was fine.
SpaceX just launched four people
up into space.
After filming this, did you have
any more of a desire
to go to space or less?
-I started with zero desir
and came away with even less
There isn't enough money
in the world.
I couldn't -- Yeah,
I would rather be
in a vat full of scorpions
covered in boils.
No, no, the very idea of
floating around in space
and being trapped in
a metal tube with strangers, no.
-I also feel like
most space movies,
that thing happens where
things don't go wrong quickly.
Like, you have two weeks o
knowing it's going wrong.
The pit of scorpions,
I also would choose that,
because I feel like
it would be fast terror
and then it would ultimately
be over,
as opposed to two weeks of
"No, it's still really bad."
And you're
in this tiny, floating...
-It's really bad,
but it's two weeks.
So, eventually, we're gonn
have to make small talk
and ask, like,
"What was your mom like?"
-[ Laughing ] Right.
-You're just with these people
and Elon Musk.
Like, "Okay, let's talk
like things are normal,
but one of us is probably
gonna die at the end of this."
-Yeah, and I know, obviously
based on your reaction
to not being here in person,
I know
missing out on the small tal
is pretty much your main game.
-It's my game, yeah.
Which one of us is going to die?
The next time
I'm there in person,
that's the question that you
and I need to get --
-That's what I'm gonna do.
You know what?
I'm not gonna ask you how
the weather has been for you
or how your travel was.
I'm just gonna walk in and say
"Real talk -- which one of us do
you think is gonna die first?"
-"There's a bullet in this gun
One of us is gonna eat it.
Let's go."
-We mentioned in your intr
your award nominations.
You were 12 years old.
I don't think I realized
you were 12 years old
when you were nominated
for a Tony.
That must have been
quite an experience.
-Yeah, I have now lost
all of the EGOTs.
-Oh, congrats.
-Thank you very much. Thank you.
-Should that be called a LEGOT
Like a loser for the EGOTs
-I like that, I like that.
"Yeah, she's a LEGOT."
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
I lost my Tony,
when I was 12 years old,
to Audra McDonald,
'cause she's got like 40.
So...
-Yeah.
I had, like,
a weird full-circle thing
where the last time I presente
at the Tonys,
she was there
and she came up to me.
And she was like, "My daughter
is a big fan of yours.
She's like 12, and
she wants to meet you."
And so I started, like,
info-dumping in her face
about how it was this incredible
circle-of-life thing.
And she was like, "Cool.
Can you take a picture
with my daughter?
I'm Audra McDonald.
I have 40 Tonys."
-Yeah, she was like,
"Can we do this fast?
'cause they're
about to give me a Tony,
and I really need to be
out there when they do."
-"There are like 20 more.
They made up categories.
I'm that good."
-Thank you so much
for being here.
It's always so delightful
to see you.
And congrats on the movie.
-Thanks, man. Good to see you.
-"Stowaway" is streaming
on Netflix now.